so initially I intended to upload a
video today about Kyle Rayner and then I
was like wait a minute
we didn't do Suicide Squad so here you
go we're only gonna do Suicide Squad for
you guys so the Suicide Squad team has a
very long-standing history in the realm
of DC Comics and it actually first
appears and braven the bold issue number
25 in 1959 and the group was actually
created or the concept was created by a
man named Robert can occur now The Brave
and the bold were a series of comics
that featured team ups between major and
minor DC characters in an attempt to
boost the popularity of the minor
characters and so it made sense that we
would one see the brave or I guess see
the Suicide Squad introduced and braving
the bold and - we would see them
introduced using the same format and so
the whole reason behind the Suicide
Squad introduction the whole reason why
they were given to us was because if you
guys recall our previous videos we had
talked about how Marvel and DC were a
hotbed of experimentation in the 1950s
in the 1960s and so the Suicide Squad
was a reflection of this rather than
focusing on superheroes that weren't
wildly popular during this time DC
instead decided to establish a team that
would undertake suicidal missions where
they would function in the same capacity
as superheroes albeit without any real
powers now again this original team as
it was led by Rick Flagg only appeared
for about six issues and it wouldn't be
until Christ on Infinite Earths and the
reboot of DC's continuity following this
crisis that the team would return in
1987 with a secret origin story that
would actually cover the bases of the
original team as well as how it was this
new team came into existence what we
find with the secret origin is that Rick
Flagg senior had previously served as
the United States or I guess in the
United States Army under the mantle of
the suicide squadron now we're not
explicitly told why this military group
was called the suicide squadron but I
would surmise that it's due to the fact
that the team basically involved itself
in a series of risky missions for the
most part they were usually deemed to be
suicidal and so what we learn is that
due to the Joseph McCarthy era politics
of accusing everyone of
the Communists which is true the Justice
Society of America which was the
precursor to the Justice League had
actually vacated their position and rick
flagg was basically commissioned by the
President of the United States to fill
in as leader of a de facto superhero
group now the result was that the group
seemed to be immensely successful in
their endeavors but after the death of
his wife rick flagg seniors basically
left to raise his son by himself and so
most of the values that rick flagg
senior had learned over the course of
his life were instilled in a son rick
flagg jr. but as it's explained to us
rick flagg senior seemed basically a be
beyond the point of recovery and so
during a mission with a Nazi war machine
writ flight senior basically sacrificed
his life and so what he did was he
basically left his son rick flagg jr. to
carry on the mantle of everything that
his father had taught him now with the
reintroduction of the suicide squad in
1987 as part of the continuity of the
crisis on Infinite Earths what we find
here is that the writing duties are
basically handed over to John Ostrander
who would actually stay on his writer
for the series until about 1992 now
we'll actually see him return but what
Aundre did is he placed a suicide squad
under the control of a woman named
Amanda Waller who was sort of this
on-again off-again hero and villain in
the DC Universe that's really kind of
contextual is based on what stories DC's
writing and it evens it's even based on
the writer himself or herself but
between 1987 and 1992 the Suicide Squad
was known for quite a few achievements
it actually brought the team from the
realm of obscurity to the main stage in
DC Comics in issue number 23 for example
Barbara Gordon made her first appearance
after having been shot by the Joker
during The Killing Joke as well as
composing the team of villains looking
for redemption now the importance of
Barbara Gordon here was that prior to
Barbara Gordon having made her debut as
a work will and the Suicide Squad she
was considered by a lot of people to be
a character that had no real purpose
anymore her ability to fight as that
woman was gone she couldn't move she
couldn't walk and so the result here was
what role is she going to play with DC
introducing her as Oracle they
effectively made her a main stage
character they basically came along and
stated in the comic book publications
that even though a person is handicapped
they can still perform just as
adequately as a person who's not in
addition to this The Suicide Squad
established that at any
time any member of the team could be
killed off and replaced by another
member of the team or another person who
was looking to become part of the team
and so with a team originally consisted
of blockbuster bronze Tiger Captain
Boomerang Deadshot and enchantress by
the time a series came to an end in 1992
rick flagg jr. had been killed off the
leader of the team was gone and the new
roster consisted of poison ivy bronze
tiger nightshade Captain Boomerang
Deadshot and count vertigo
now with the cancellation of volume 1 in
1992 the series returned for about 12
issues in 2001 under Keith Griffin but
the series just didn't really see enough
interest and sales for DC to pick the
series of as a long as an ongoing series
and so rather than seeing it continue on
for the long term what we found was that
while it had kind of a cult following
while it did have her usual fans a
Suicide Squad that read it that in 2002
DC canceled the series entirely now
rather than attempting to bring the
series back for an extended run DC
instead chose to basically test the
waters to see whether or not the
popularity was still there by handing
the writing duties over to John
Ostrander to basically bring him back
for a second time in the Suicide Squad
since his original run is considered by
many to be one of the best runs of the
team and so what he did is he produced
an eighth issue miniseries that appeared
in 2007 now again where previous writers
had tried to establish an ongoing
continuity John Ostrander instead chose
to focus on highlighting and elevating
minor characters so that when the
miniseries ended that these characters
will be able to move on to larger roles
that had previously been assigned to
them or else they never would have seen
but the plan itself that is to say the
goal of John Ostrander actually proved
to be a success and that several of the
characters such as Captain Boomerang
count vertigo and others actually found
themselves thrust into other stories
were made consistent villains for some
of the larger tier superheroes in DC
Comics like the flash and so on now by
2011 and the launch of DC's new 52 with
their reboot of the entire DC Universe -
Batman and the Green Lantern Suicide
Squad was looked at as a title to
receive a new lineup new writer and a
new series of stories and this was
mostly or at least it appeared to be due
to the history that the suicide school
had and DC Comics as well as this kind
of on-again off-again popularity among
casual comic book readers and so the
result was that DC began looking at
characters that would be most likely to
draw readers N and so continuing with
the theme of Amanda Waller as director
of the group DC basically organized the
following line up as part of Suicide
Squad volume four these members included
black spider Captain Boomerang Deadshot
El Diablo James Gordon jr. King shark
Harley Quinn the Unknown Soldier in yoyo
not all the most popular carriers and
teams as part of the new 52 line up in
DC saw a huge jump in sales with their
Rockets with the issue number ones of
their respective titles this Suicide
Squad didn't and said issue number one
only saw about 44,000 issues that were
sold in the month compared to Batman and
Green Lantern that sold anywhere between
180 thousand to a hundred and forty-four
thousand number ones respectively and so
the result was that while the sales of
Suicide Squad basically continued a
slump they continued to drop off the DC
kept the theme of the Suicide Squad
being this sort of underdog by removing
some of the previous members in
establishing the new Suicide Squad and
his current run which is composed of
Black Manta Captain Boomerang Deadshot
Joker's daughter alongside Harley Quinn
and the reverse-flash with that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it I think it was interesting doing the
whole Suicide Squad thing it's about
time yeah I know a lot of you DC fans
were like it's about time you did
Suicide Squad Roth so already go ahead
and bounce off here and I will catch you
guys later peace